une très grande sensibilité
beaucoup de valeur
passionné je m'appelle georges dijoux
plus connues dans le monde artistique
sous le nom de dj mag qui reprend
simplement les initiales de mon nom
prénom dont dijoux jean marie dei et gmc
c'est pour me présenter j'ai 48 ans ça
fait maintenant
25 ans que je suis artiste sculpteur
donc j'ai touché un petit peu à tout le
bois la pierre le basalte le marbre et
depuis deux ans maintenant les métaux
mais capable de travailler le bois une
train capable de travailler la pierre il
est capable de travailler le métal
on ne manque qu'une fois une technique
de suite ils se l'approprient
on a l'impression que c'est inné chez
lui c'est cool insiste là-dessus c'est
tellement petit qu'on peut lui donner la
forme qu'on a envie donc rentrer dans
les creux passé sur les bosses formé
l'épaule former la poitrine former le le
le drapé par les écrous complètement de
volume et de tailles différentes peu
permet de créer tout ça justement alors
vive et artistes il aimait artistes chez
en lui c'est pas quelque chose qu'il a
mis en place sur lequel il s'est formé
c'est en lui c'est vital il faut qu'ils
créent et parce qu'il en a besoin c'est
un mode d'expression
donc on vit avec un artiste dont je vis
avec lui et je vis avec ce côté artiste
qu'il est donc oui je les accepte
intégralement dans tout ce qu'il est et
bien sûr ça donne cette grande
sensibilité ça donne cette créativité à
fleur de peau c'est tout ça qui fait de
lui l'artiste qui l'est c'est pas une
formation c'est lui mais comme ça ça
fait partie aussi de mon environnement
quoi c'est l'air c'est la réunion c'est
mon
c'est mon petit coin c'est mais baleine
c'est les réunionnais fait j'adore
j'adore